wenn die pandemie einen tunnel ist wie
nah ist dann das licht an seinem ende
von der politik in dieser woche keine
navigation keine klare
krisenkommunikation man hat sich
verfahren wir können nicht weiter das
gesamte land unter schutz stellen um
eine klar in einer gruppe von
impfwilligen
und denjenigen die beraten nicht bereit
sind die massnahmen mitzutragen um diese
zu schützen
das verfahren ist unsäglich die länder
sind keiner weise beteiligt worden und
wer hat es auch inhaltlich für falsch
wir müssen aus der angst basierten
bewohner politik heraus sondern
vernünftige politik wir können nicht das
einzige land in europa sein was wieder
glaubt es besser zu wissen dass alle
anderen der ländervergleich jedenfalls
den gesundheitsminister lauterbach diese
woche anstellt ist falsch er behauptet
deutschland hat jetzt höchste corona
inzidenz in europa lauterbach irrt die
deutsche incidents liegt bei 1708 ist in
österreich praktisch doppelt so hoch
auch die schweiz hat eine deutlich
höhere incidents genau wie die
niederlande aber dort sind sie dem
tunnelausgang trotzdem schon viel näher
in den niederlanden fallen am kommenden
mittwoch die masken überall es ist das
ende aller maßnahmen der niederländische
gesundheitsminister kann sich das lachen
nicht verkneifen als er nach deutschland
gefragt wird
über die german angst kann ich natürlich
nur wenig sagen aber was wir die letzten
zwei monate gemacht haben hier in den
niederlanden das war schrittweise
lockern in dem wissen dass das erstmal
zuhören infektionen führen würde aber
jetzt sehen wir die zahlen langsam
sinken und das ist günstig das bedeutet
dass man die verantwortung wieder mehr
dem einzelnen übertragen muss wir
brauchen das nicht mehr als stadt von
oben auferlegen
auch der deutsche gesundheitsminister
versucht sich diese woche locker zu
machen
doch er sendet dabei widersprüchliche
signale im bundestag verteidigt
lauterbach die neuen öffnungen in
interviews aber gibt er weiter den
warner und mahner also gefährlichste
wäre wenn wirklich omikron gefährlicher
würde also die delta variante kann zu
bekommen es kann sich aber auch eine
kombination zwischen delta und mikron
entwickeln aber wenn die lage sich
verändert dann würden wir sofort
herangehen und würden das gesetz
überarbeiten die omikron welle in
relation gesetzt zur ersten schweren
winter welle die infektionszahlen jetzt
um ein vielfaches höher
krankenhaus intensivbetten belegungen
und todeszahlen dafür heute
vergleichsweise niedrig die kurve die
virologen im gesundheitsausschuss auch
nach zwei jahren aber immer noch völlig
verschieden deuten was leider passieren
kann es dass das wachstum sich so
dynamisch entwickelt das die kontrolle
komplett verlieren ich hatte eben nicht
sehr viel davon dass man da immer den
teufel an die wand malt und mit neuen
szenarien spielt freedom day vielleicht
vielleicht doch nicht die kritik am
geänderten
infektionsschutzgesetz kommt von allen
seiten zu unkonkret heißt es
handwerklich schlecht gemacht mangelhaft
kommuniziert und das fing ja schon
besonders charmant an weil wir in der
nacht von dienstag auf mittwoch morgens
mit wasser aus und 16 eine mail
erhielten aus dem bundesminister für
gesundheit mit dem gesetzesentwurf wir
sollten dann bis mittwoch um 10 uhr
stellung bezogen haben und das ist
natürlich eine farce muss man sagen das
hat mit beteiligung von experten
organisationen nichts zu tun dies ist
weder das team vorsicht noch das 7
freiheit und schon gar nicht das team
augenmaß dies ist das team blindflug die
fdp löst ein wahlkampfversprechen
einsetzt sich als kleinster
koalitionspartner durch die ein oder
andere krokodilstränen vergossen wird
die muss man doch auch eine ordnung wenn
also immer so getan würde als bestünde
bei der korona politik in der
vergangenheit einmütigkeit habe der
einmütigkeit bestanden gerade die das im
moment so besonders laut öffentlich
rufen man früher immer die ersten die
sich aus den beschlüssen der mpk
verabschiedet haben die grünen halten
die lockerungen für verfrüht sie leiden
an der fdp und fühlen sich von olaf
scholz hängen gelassen da war eben nicht
mehr drin als dieser minimalkonsens wir
sind damit nicht zufrieden und natürlich
hätte ich mir gewünscht dass der herr
bundeskanzler
mehr rückendeckung gegeben hätte nach
100 tagen erste risse im ampel frieden
und das licht am ende des corona tunnels
kommt wenn überhaupt nur langsam näher